O que eu quero falar hoje na aula é
uma noção teórica do jogo
conhecido como o Dilema do Prisioneiro,
que pode ser usado para
caracterizar uma estrutura
trazida tanto no Livro II de A
República de Platão
quanto no Capítulo 13 de O
Leviatã de Hobbes.
E o propósito ao apresentá-los
a esta maneira de pensar
é exatamente o que estamos fazendo
durante todo o semestre.
É pegar um conjunto tradicional
de questões filosóficas
e perguntar como é que a
metodologia de outra disciplina
pode lançar uma luz sobre essas
questões de forma complementar.
Portanto vocês se lembram, no início
da última aula, que eu comecei
com uma citação do início do Livro
II de A República de Platão,
quando Glauco responde ao
desafio de Sócrates
para articular a natureza e as
origens da justiça
– a natureza e as origens
do, a grosso modo,
comportamento pró-social.
E eu destaquei que a
alegação feita por Glauco
tem o seguinte formato:
"Os homens afirmam que é bom cometer
a injustiça e mau sofrê-la,
mas que há mais mal em sofrê-la
do que bem em cometê-la.
Por isso, quando mutuamente a
cometem e a sofrem
e experimentam as duas situações, os
que não podem evitar um nem
escolher o outro julgam
útil entender-se
para não voltarem a cometer nem
a sofrer a injustiça.
" E nós ilustramos, com o
exemplo dos 2 pastores,
que um deles rouba os cavalos do outro
e adquire uma certa quantidade
de prazer com isso,
mas não o equivalente ao
desgosto adquirido
pelo companheiro roubado.
Portanto, os 2 acabam numa
situação com menos utilidade
do que se cooperassem e se juntam
e formam uma espécie de pacto.
Glauco segue com a passagem que eu
também li na última classe.
Ele diz que a justiça "situa-se
entre o maior bem e o maior mal.
O maior bem é cometer
impunemente a injustiça.
O maior mal é sofrê-la quando se
é incapaz de vingança.
A justiça é um meio entre
esse dois extremos".
Mas eu não li para vocês
a frase seguinte,
que vamos enfocar na aula de hoje.
Porque Glauco continua
apontando que, na sua visão,
se você estava pensando em justiça
como esse tipo de coordenação, sob
uma perspectiva matemática...
Eu posso pedir para
alguém ajustar a porta
para que ela não bata quando
as pessoas entrem?
O que ele diz é:
"A justiça é apreciada não
como um bem em si mesma,
mas porque a impotência para cometer
a injustiça lhe dá valor".
Alguém que tem o poder de prejudicar
o outro sem ser prejudicado,
alguém que tem o poder de
fazer isso, no entanto,
não faria um acordo com ninguém
para não cometer injustiça,
a fim de não sofrê-la.
Porque, para ele, seria loucura.
Então Glauco nos deu um argumento,
que vamos rever daqui a pouco em Hobbes,
que tem o seguinte formato:
É racional quando você pensa
que não há outra escolha
senão cooperar.
Mas se você acha que pode
se safar agindo
de forma não-cooperativa,
enquanto a outra pessoa coopera,
seria insano cooperar.
Seria uma loucura.
Hobbes faz exatamente a
mesma ponderação
no Capítulo 13 de O Leviatã.
Você se lembram que ele articula as 2
primeiras leis de natureza.
As leis de natureza são normas
a que os seres racionais qua seres
racionais são obrigados a seguir,
porque eles as reconhecem assim,
aumentando a probabilidade
de preservação
e prosperidade nas suas próprias vidas.
Assim, a 1ª lei de natureza é
uma lei de 2 partes.
Ela diz para buscar a paz, se
há uma chance de paz,
e se não, para se envolver em guerra.
A 2ª lei de natureza, como
vocês se lembram,
também articula um
compromisso condicional
para abrir mão de um certo
tipo de liberdade.
A 2ª lei de natureza diz
para estar disposto a
abdicar dos seus direitos
na medida em que os outros estão
dispostos a fazer o mesmo
e se contentar com o
máximo de liberdade
que aos outros homens permitem
em relação a si mesmo.
Então, novamente, como na
1ª lei de natureza,
a renúncia dos direitos
está condicionada
aos outros renunciarem dos
direitos também.
Como Glauco, Hobbes
expressa a preocupação
de que isso pode não ser viável.
Ele escreve: "Se os outros homens não
renunciarem ao direito deles,
assim como você, não há razão
para você se despojar disso.
Proceder assim seria se
oferecer como presa,
coisa a que ninguém é obrigado, e
não a se dispor para a paz".
Nós vamos usar os clickers
após o próximo slide,
por isso, vocês podem começar a
pegá-los e se prepararem.
Agora, eu sei que alguns de vocês
nesta aula cursam Economia
e alguns de vocês estão em
Teoria dos Jogos.
E, por isso, eu peço desculpas
da maneira que eu me peço desculpas
aos que são de Filosofia
ao apresentá-los a um nível básico
de A República de Platão.
Mas este é um recurso que todos
nós precisamos entender
e eu prometo que, em poucos minutos,
nós vamos jogar alguns jogos reais.
Portanto, o dilema do prisioneiro
é uma forma de representar graficamente
a estrutura para o que Glauco
e Hobbes advertiram.
E isso envolve representar algumas
escolhas por algumas pessoas
numa matriz de 2 a 2.
Assim que, por um lado,
há uma pessoa A,
que enfrenta 2 possibilidades de ação.
A 1ª é que ela pode se
comportar de forma pacífica,
abdicando dos seus direitos de
atacar o seu inimigo e, assim,
conceder-se um certo tipo de liberdade.
Ou ela pode reservar para si o
direito de guerra e, assim,
produzir em seu adversário um
sentimento de ameaça.
A sua contraparte, B, enfrenta
exatamente o mesmo par de escolhas.
Ela pode se comportar de forma pacífica
e abdicar do seu direito de
atacar ou pode reservar
os prazeres da guerra para
momentos em que ela se sente,
seja de forma preventiva ou retaliativa,
a necessidade de se envolver num
comportamento ameaçador.
O que é importante observar
sobre o dilema... desculpem.
Portanto, isso nos dá 4 possibilidades.
Ou A e B se comportam de
forma pacífica.
Isto é, satisfazem a cláusula inicial
da 1ª da lei de natureza de Hobbes.
Elas apertam as mãos do
desafio de Glauco;
cada uma dá a mesma
quantidade que Hobbes fala
na 2ª lei de natureza.
Ou, elas podem estar num estado
de guerra entre elas.
Isto é o que Glauco acha que
emergirá naturalmente
e o que Hobbes pensa que é o
caso do estado de natureza.
Ou pode ser o caso de A,
a letra à esquerda se refere a A, se
comporte de forma pacífica,
ao passo que B se comporte
de forma guerreira.
Ou pode ser o caso em que A se
comporta de forma guerreira,
enquanto que B se comporta
de forma pacífica.
Agora o que é importante observar
sobre a estrutura do
dilema do prisioneiro
é que A tem o controle sobre a linha.
A pode determinar se estamos
nesta linha ou nesta.
Mas A não tem o controle da coluna.
B, por outro lado, tem o
controle da coluna
e não tem controle da linha.
B pode determinar se estamos
na coluna da esquerda
ou na coluna da direita, mas
não pode determinar
o seu comportamento se estamos na
linha de cima ou de baixo.
Agora, eu quero dar a
partida tendo a certeza
de que todo mundo entendeu a
estrutura deste problema,
porque eu estou prestes a botar
um pouco de dinheiro real
no jogo e quero ter a certeza de
que, ao tomarem a decisão,
exista a compreensão da
estrutura do caso.
Então deixa eu começar falando
sobre a estrutura de preferências de A
em relação aos resultados e,
em seguida, pedir que vocês me digam
qual é a escolha racional para A.
Como sabemos por Glauco, a
1ª escolha geral
é reservar para si todos os direitos,
tendo o oponente abdicando
dos direitos dele.
Portanto, a 1ª escolha de A é
que A seja guerreiro
e B pacífico.
A 4ª escolha geral, como Glauco aponta,
é ser pego tendo abdicado das armas
quando o inimigo não fez mesmo.
Cooperar quando o inimigo
não está cooperando.
Então essa é a 4ª escolha de A.
Mas tanto Glauco quanto Hobbes destacam,
entre a escolha de paz-paz
e guerra-guerra,
ou seja, um estado de natureza
ou o estado de sociedade
em que houve uma renúncia
mútua dos direitos,
é a 2ª opção de todo mundo, em
especial a 2ª opção de A,
estar num estado de paz, e a
3ª escolha de A,
estar num estado de guerra total.
Portanto, a pergunta a ser respondida...
a escolha feita por A é a da linha.
A pode se colocar numa linha
onde ele vai obter a sua 2ª
ou a sua 4ª escolha.
Ou pode se colocar numa linha
onde ele vai obter a sua 1ª
ou a sua 3ª escolha.
Essa é a decisão que A tem de fazer.
2ª ou 4ª escolha contra
1ª ou 3ª escolha.
É isso aí.
A pergunta que vocês vão
responder nos seus clickers é:
Dada essa matriz, qual é a
escolha racional de A?
É racional escolher a linha 1,
onde A vai ter a sua 2ª ou 4ª escolha;
ou é racional escolher a linha 2,
onde A vai ter a sua 1ª ou 3ª escolha?
OK. Então...
Os 4% que querem punir o cara
que não faz as coisas que
estão erradas,
fatiar o cara que apareceu
ingenuamente no hospital
e escolher a opção dominada na
matriz do Dilema do Prisioneiro
estão sempre aqui.
Quem está lendo artigos de psicologia
e se pergunta por que é que ao
fazer a análise estatística
é preciso deixar espaço para
o erro experimental,
pode ver melhor que nunca, aqui,
por que isso é assim.
Mas 96% das respostas
apresentaram o que é,
inerentemente, a estrutura
desta situação, ou seja,
que dada uma opção entre a paz,
onde A vai obter a sua 2ª
ou 4ª escolha,
e a guerra, 1ª ou 3ª escolha,
a coisa óbvia para A fazer é
escolher a linha de baixo.
Portanto, já temos a decisão de A.
O que é racional para A fazer é
escolher a linha de baixo.
A situação para B é, claro,
exatamente simétrica.
B escolhe a coluna, então
B pode escolher...
a 1ª escolha de B seria
que A é pacífico
enquanto B é guerreiro,
a 4ª escolha de B é que A é
guerreiro, enquanto ele é pacífico.
A 2ª escolha de B é paz-paz
e a 3ª escolha de B é guerra-guerra.
Apenas checando de novo para
ver se consigo me livrar
desses 4% residuais...
Qual é a escolha racional para B
fazer nesta situação?
Se vocês fizerem um bom trabalho aqui,
vamos trabalhar com dinheiro vivo.
Qual é a escolha racional para B
fazer nesta situação,
visto que a paz fornece a
2ª ou 4ª escolha
e a guerra a 1ª ou 3ª?
Vamos conferir os números
que saem desta vez.
3, 2, 1 segundo e...
[risos]
Profª. Tamar Gendler: Ha ha ha.
Tudo bem. Excelente. Então, vamos lá.
92% de vocês têm
dado uma resposta racional
e 8% de vocês, sempre e anonimamente,
serão conhecidos por ter se
colocado na situação 1.
Portanto, a estrutura do
dilema do prisioneiro
em relação a B também é
que a coluna rejeitada
é a coluna pacífica.
Então o que temos é uma situação
onde A determina a linha...
desculpe, onde B determina a coluna
e escolhe a coluna guerreira.
A determina a linha e escolhe
a linha guerreira.
E o resultado disso é que se trata
de uma situação estável
nos dilemas desse tipo que todo mundo
termine com a 3ª escolha.
Agora, a estrutura que acabei de
descrever, no contexto
da questão do contrato social
no estilo Glauco-Hobbes
é, naturalmente, uma estrutura
que surge repetidas vezes.
Qualquer situação de escolha em
que a pessoa escolhe a coluna
tem uma ordem como esta
e que a pessoa escolhe a linha
tem uma ordem como esta.
Ou seja, qualquer situação em que
há assimetria na 1ª e 4ª
escolhas e simetria na 2ª e 3ª
acaba colocando as pessoas, de forma
estável, numa situação
onde ambas acabam com a sua 3ª opção.
Por exemplo, nós somos policiais
e colocamos os criminosos num dilema,
é por isso que se chama
Dilema do Prisioneiro...
em que incentivamos a
confissão unilateral
em vez de permanecer em
silêncio, o que vai passar
é que ambos prisioneiros serão
motivados a confessar,
terminando na 3ª
escolha, em vez da 2ª,
que seria ambos ficarem em silêncio.
Se estamos numa corrida
armamentista nuclear com outro
país
onde o desarmamento mútuo
deixaria os 2 países com um
dividendo da paz,
talvez o medo de que a
outra parte deserte
e o medo de talvez acabar
numa dessas células,
vai empurrar ambas as partes
para a 3ª escolha.
A 3ª escolha.
Se nos deparamos com a situação
descrita no início da leitura de hoje,
a história de Hume sobre
os 2 indivíduos,
em que ambos se beneficiariam
se drenassem o pântano no seu campo,
mas nenhum dos 2 quer ser o
único a fazê-lo,
temos uma situação não-cooperativa.
E você enfrenta situações análogas
em qualquer tipo de cenário cooperativo
onde a cooperação de
várias pessoas produziria
um resultado benéfico para o
grupo como um todo,
mas nenhum indivíduo quer ser aquele
que assuma o ônus indevido.
A vacinação é outro exemplo de
um dilema do prisioneiro.
Há um baixo risco existente
associado a vacinar o seu filho
ou você contra uma doença.
Há um risco muito, muito baixo de a
criança ficar muito doente
e um risco um pouco moderado de a
criança ter uma doença leve.
Por outro lado, se
ninguém fosse vacinado,
seria muito pior.
E, na verdade, a motivação de não
se vacinar seria dissipada.
Assim, de forma mais geral, os
dilemas dos prisioneiros surgem
quando a situação
cooperativa é dominada
pela situação de deserção.
E o quebra-cabeça que vamos comentar
depois de analisar mais alguns
exemplos é a forma como,
na sua totalidade, é possível se mover
desta célula para esta célula.
Então, como eu indiquei, os
dilemas dos prisioneiros
surgem em casos assimétricos, onde
a cooperação unilateral
é a opção mais custosa,
onde a deserção unilateral é a
opção mais benéfica,
onde a deserção bilateral
é um pouco custosa
e onde a cooperação
bilateral é algo benéfico.
Bom, como é que vamos
fazer isso nesta aula?
Aqui está a resposta.
Este é o dilema da sala de
aula... e é para valer.
É real.
O dinheiro está aqui e eu tenho uma
lista com os nomes dos alunos
que vão ganhar dinheiro em
cada dilema que jogarmos.
Estamos jogando 3 agora mesmo.
Um de vocês, e eu vou
dizer quem depois,
vai conseguir uma das
seguintes gratificações.
Se você escolher 1 e a
maioria da sala escolher 1,
você receberá US$ 15.
Se você escolher 1 e a
maioria da sala escolher 1,
você receberá US$ 15.
Aqui está uma nota de US$ 20.
Se você escolher 2 e a
maioria da sala escolher 1,
você receberá US$ 50.
US$ 50.
Estou apostando na teoria
dos jogos aqui.
Se você escolher 1 e a maioria
da classe escolher 2...
eu queria colocar uma punição aqui,
mas eu não posso pedir
dinheiro para vocês.
Então, você não vai receber nada.
Se você escolher 2 e a
maioria da sala escolher 2,
você receberá US$ 5.
Agora, só para salientar que
eu tenho palavra...
a Sarah Cox está aqui hoje? Sarah Cox.
Sarah, você ganhou US$ 5 em março...
Desculpe, foi no dia 15 de fevereiro?
Sim.
A Sarah Cox conseguiu US$ 5.
E revisando as minhas notas eu vi
que eu não selecionei
ninguém para o 2º prêmio
e 22 e 24 de março foi na
semana passada, assim que...
Tara Abraham, você está aqui?
Uau.
Tara Abraham, você vai receber US$ 6,
porque eu vou supor que
você estava nos 97%.
Venha pegar o seu dinheiro
depois da aula.
OK.
Então, eu quero reforçar que
estou falando sério,
aqui está o dilema da sala de aula.
Aqui está.
Se você escolher 1, vai
ter US$ 15 ou nada,
dependendo do que a
maioria da turma fizer.
Se você escolher 2
– eu juro, isso é sério –,
vai ter US$ 50 ou US$ 5,
dependendo do que o resto
da turma fizer.
É sério.
Podem começar a clicar.
Apenas 8 de vocês?
Ninguém quer dinheiro?
Eu vou acionar o contador de tempo.
Não percam a chance.
Isto é dinheiro real.
Há uma lista de nomes aqui, de verdade.
Essas 2 pessoas que eu chamei
estão realmente aqui.
Não são plantas.
Se você não está aqui alguém
vai conseguir o dinheiro.
Então, deem o lance de vocês.
Vocês têm 10, 9, 8...
vamos ver se a teoria dos
jogos está do meu lado.
Tudo bem, vamos ver o que temos.
OK.
A maioria da classe escolheu
2... então, ali estou eu.
E o indivíduo selecionado
é o Charles Holmes.
Charles Holmes, você está aqui?
O Charles Holmes não está
recebendo o que o Charles Holmes
poderia receber, que é 0 ou US$ 5...
bem, o Charles está
ficando sem dólares,
mas não como resultado disto.
Sello Lekalakala, você está aqui?
Sello Lekalakala...
você deu uma resposta, Sello...
1 ou 2?
Você respondeu 2.
Sello, depois da aula, você pode vir
aqui e pegar os seus US$ 5.
Vamos tentar de novo.
Vamos ver se eu vou ter de
pagar os US$ 50.
OK? Eu estava apostando que teria
de dar US$ 5, e assim foi.
Observem pessoal, vocês foram parar
no canto inferior direito
do Dilema do Prisioneiro.
OK? Vamos tentar de novo.
Mesmo jogo.
Tentando de novo.
Estou realmente arriscando, não?
Vamos em frente.
Façam o que puderem.
Tentem conseguir os US$ 50.
Deem o melhor de vocês.
Tudo bem. 49 de vocês.
Deixa eu acionar o contador e vamos
ver como os números saem.
Vamos ver em 4, 3, 2, 1 segundo...
ao vivo na TV de audiências: 68 e 32.
OK, então mais uma vez a
maioria optou pelo 2.
Então, vamos ver o que o
vencedor vai receber.
US$ 50 ou US$ 5.
Desculpem, US$ 0 ou US$ 5.
A vencedora desta vez é a Helen Wang.
Helen Wang, você vai
receber US$ 0 ou US$ 5?
Você está aqui, Helen?
OK. Helen, você deu...
você está recebendo US$ 0 ou US$ 5?
Você está recebendo US$ 5.
Excelente. Tudo bem.
Eu estou colocando outros US$ 5.
Vamos tentar mais uma vez.
A teoria dos jogos está do meu lado.
Pessoal, vocês estão no
canto inferior direito.
Qual é? Este é o dilema do
prisioneiro para vocês.
Vamos tentar mais uma vez.
Qual vocês escolhem?
Mesma aposta outra vez.
OK? Eu tenho o dinheiro aqui.
Eu o roubei da caixa do bar
Mitzvah do meu filho.
Eu não tenho dinheiro em casa,
mas ele tinha um monte.
Tudo bem.
Mas, felizmente, eu poder pagá-lo
de volta a maior parte,
então ele ficará grato.
OK. E vamos conferir os números.
49 de vocês lá em cima novamente.
10, 9, 8, 7, 6, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
Vamos ver se eu vou perder dinheiro.
54%.
Vocês estão chegando perto.
Ah ha. Eu arrisquei 3 vezes,
pensando que eu não teria de
arriscar uma 4ª vez...
OK.
Assim, o vencedor desta
vez, Jared Jones.
Jared Jones, você está aqui?
Jared Jones, OK.
Jared, você recebe US$ 0 ou US$ 5?
Você escolheu 2.
Então, outra vez US$ 5, e nós
estamos no canto inferior direito
do dilema do prisioneiro.
OK pessoal, vocês perderam o
dividendo da paz, certo?
Teria sido melhor se, de alguma forma,
pudéssemos ter terminado na
célula meio a meio.
E o dividendo da cooperação,
que não estava disponível para
vocês porque estamos
numa sala grande e todos estão
sentados em fileiras,
sem poder conspirar e sem
mecanismos de aplicação.
O dividendo da cooperação estava
indisponível para vocês.
Como o dividendo da
cooperação se parece?
Bem, se parece com isto:
Aqui estão os 2 pastores no
estado de natureza
e cada um cuida de um jardim.
Mas porque é o estado de
natureza, o sujeito verde
vai até o jardim do sujeito
vermelho e rouba um tomate,
e o vermelho, irritado com o verde,
vai até o jardim do outro
e o devasta com uma foice.
Então o homem verde diz:
"Eu não quero que o cara vermelho venha
e destrua o meu jardim com uma foice.
Eu vou colocar uma cerca em
volta do jardim"...
e ele se empenha em fazer isso.
E o vermelho diz:
"Eu não quero que o sujeito verde
roube os meus tomates"...
e ele coloca uma cerca em
volta do jardim.
No entanto, se eles podiam ter
cooperado de alguma forma,
ter feito algum tipo de acordo
de que ficariam longe do
jardim do outro,
em vez de se empenhar na
construção de cercas,
eles poderiam ter se esforçado
para o que Hobbes chama
de características da
vida confortável.
Assim, o sujeito verde poderia ter
tido um lindo jardim florido
que atrai os beija-flores
e o vermelho poderia ter
desenvolvido um dispositivo
que prevê o movimento dos planetas.
Quando não temos de gastar energia
com coisas como proteger a
nossa propriedade,
nós temos energia de sobra para
coisas como a vida confortável.
E só para lembrá-los onde isso se
encaixa no contexto das coisas,
esta é a explicação de Hobbes
para por que é racional nos
envolvermos num contrato social.
O que eu quero fazer agora é
apresentar uma 2ª noção
intimamente relacionada com a do
dilema do prisioneiro.
Ou seja, o Problema dos Comuns.
E eu vou dar 3 exemplos e, em
seguida, vamos jogar outro jogo.
E tem mais dinheiro em cima da mesa...
sobrou um monte da última rodada.
Então aqui está o Problema dos Comuns.
A Tragédia dos Comuns.
Vamos supor que você viva
numa bela área verde
e você e os seus colegas
pastores tenham 1 vaca cada um.
Você coloca a sua vaca no
pasto, para pastar,
e está tudo correndo bem.
O pasto é grande e
agradável e, na verdade,
você estaria melhor se tivesse
não 1, mas 2 vacas.
Então, você e cada um dos
seus colegas pastores
adquire uma 2ª vaca e as
coloca no pasto.
Mas, claro, se 2 vacas é
bom, 3 vacas é melhor.
Então, você e cada um dos
seus colegas pastores
coloca a sua vaca extra para pastar;
agora cada um tem 3 vacas.
3 vacas ótimo... 4 vacas, formidável.
Cada um de vocês recebe uma 4ª
vaca e a coloca no pasto.
E o resultado
é que não há mais espaço
de sobra no pasto.
A pastagem é arruinada.
Os recursos escassos se esgotam
através da tragédia dos comuns.
Agora estamos na revolução industrial.
Nós superamos os nossos
dias de pastoreio.
Você e os seus colegas
industriais criam, cada um,
1 fábrica poluente.
Aqui está.
Disseminando um pouco de poluição.
Uma fábrica poluente, bem; 2
fábricas poluentes, melhor...
é o que ocorre e, com isso, o lucro.
Não tenho nem ideia por que isso
não funciona cooperativamente.
Lá vamos nós.
Você adquire a sua 3ª
fábrica super rápido...
E vem a 4ª planta para
cada um de vocês.
Resultado: todo o meio
ambiente está poluído.
Cada um de vocês fez a
coisa que era racional,
mas o efeito coordenado das ações
forneceu um resultado
descontroladamente abaixo do
ideal:
um ambiente cheio de poluição.
Observem que podemos refletir
sobre o problema favorito desta turma,
o problema da procrastinação, à
luz da tragédia dos comuns.
Vamos supor que esta é uma
representação das horas do seu dia.
E estas são as suas 9h da manhã,
este é o seu meio-dia,
aqui está as 18h e as 22h.
Bom, às 9h, ao meio-dia,
às 18h e à noite...
todos querem jogar uma
partida de Angry Birds.
Mas... sabe o quê?
1 rodada está bem, 2 rodadas... melhor.
2 rodadas, bem... 3 rodadas é ótimo.
3 rodadas é ótimo, 4
rodadas... formidável.
E, de repente, você passou o dia
inteiro jogando Angry Birds.
A estrutura que a tragédia dos comuns
nos confronta não é apenas a do
esgotamento dos recursos.
Não é apenas a da
poluição do meio ambiente
e de outros tipos de
degradação resultantes
de ações individualmente
não-problemáticas,
mas como um conjunto leva a
resultados ruins.
Também é uma forma de refletir
sobre uma das questões
que nos perguntamos
repetidamente neste curso.
Como é que estruturamos as
nossas vidas de tal modo
que as nossas metas a longo
prazo sejam alcançadas?
E quando eu digo que não estou
brincando que o tropo de A República,
que o indivíduo e a sociedade são
espelhos um do outro em aspectos
importantes, aqui está outro lugar
que eu não estou brincando.
Portanto, vamos jogar a nossa
própria tragédia dos comuns.
O nosso jogo será o seguinte...
OK. Portanto, a ideia é esta:
Cada um de vocês pode decidir,
caso o seu nome seja chamado
– e eu tenho mais nomes
na minha lista...
se vai querer uma
gratificação de US$ 1.
Se assim for, pressione 1.
Se você optar pela
gratificação de US$ 2,
pressione 2.
Ou se quiser... Ai, desculpem...
de US$ 10, pressione 2.
Ou se decide pela
gratificação de US$ 50.
US$ 50.
Há um nome nesta lista.
Há cerca de 100 clickers,
você tem 1 chance em 100 de
US$ 50 se escolher 3.
Mas o negócio é o seguinte:
Se o total solicitado é inferior a
US$ 150, eu vou recompensar
o aluno premiado com a quantia
que ele tenha optado.
Mas, se o total solicitado,
e eu digo que pensava que não
haveria mais clickers do que há,
este é um jogo mais arriscado do
que eu imaginava jogar...
mas vamos ver...
Se o total solicitado é
superior a US$ 150...
tragédia dos comuns;
o banco vai à falência, muitas
solicitações, nenhuma gratificação.
OK? Então, aí está o
jogo... 22, 23, 24...
eu vou esperar um pouco.
Eu quero um monte de
respostas para este jogo.
Vamos ver os números que saem.
Tudo bem, eu vou jogar limpo.
Eu vou começar a contagem
regressiva agora.
10, 9, 8, 7, 6, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
Só existem 85 respostas?
Talvez eu tenha de voltar às
aulas de matemática.
Não, eu não preciso
voltar à matemática.
Bancarrota!
Vocês fizeram o banco falir.
Não há nenhuma alternativa, certo?
Quer dizer, 30 vezes 10 está
muito acima dos US$ 150.
Gananciosos, gananciosos, gananciosos.
Quem não recebe o seu dólar?
Kyle Cooper, me desculpe.
Você teria conseguido uma grana,
mas agora não tem nada.
Tudo bem.
Bom, isso é uma questão
psicológica interessante:
por que é pior ficar sem nada assim
que se todo o restante de vocês
não recebessem nada?
OK.
Então, o que ocorre na tragédia dos
comuns é o que vocês veem aqui.
Ou seja, cada um de vocês
fez o que era individualmente racional,
quer dizer, 18% optou pela quantia alta.
Mas 38% de vocês escolheu os US$ 10.
Apenas 45% dos estudantes optaram
pela possibilidade da
gratificação geral.
Vocês violaram o
imperativo categórico.
Tudo bem. É a vida...
Mas a questão é:
agora que fomos apresentados a estas 2
versões de quebra-cabeças,
o Dilema do Prisioneiro
e a Tragédia dos Comuns,
que tipo de estratégias
existem para escapar delas?
Nos últimos 10 minutos da
aula, eu quero comentar
sobre um nível muito geral dos tipos
de estratégias disponíveis.
Então lembrem-se... a questão é esta:
Em 3 das 3 vezes,
todos vocês acabaram no canto inferior
direito do dilema do prisioneiro.
Vocês acabaram com a 3ª opção
e não com a que poderia ter apresentado
um resultado estável, a 2ª.
E na tragédia dos comuns, todos vocês,
como resultado da expressão de
interesse próprio racional,
acabaram numa situação em que, como um
coletivo, resultou ser a pior.
Então o que precisamos fazer para
escapar dessa situação?
Precisamos, de alguma forma,
estruturar a decisão, para tanto
diminuir a utilidade relativa do
comportamento abaixo do ideal
quanto aumentar a utilidade
relativa do comportamento ideal.
Ou seja, de alguma forma,
queremos fazer com que o caso B
não nos leve para a direita
e que o A não nos leve para
a parte de baixo.
Essa é a única maneira de
sair dessa situação.
Portanto, temos vários mecanismos
disponíveis para fazer isso.
Podemos introduzir algum tipo de
punição ou gratificação
para as células assimétricas de modo
a tornar a 1 menos atraente ou
a 4 menos repulsiva.
Para que o canto da
sereia da 1ª escolha
não atraia B no mesmo
caminho da deserção
e o medo da 4ª escolha não
atraia A para a deserção.
O resultado de fazer isso
será criar o potencial
para algum tipo de equilíbrio estável e
sustentável na célula preferida.
Ao nosso 2-2, em vez do 3-3.
Então, que tipo de mecanismos estão
disponíveis neste contexto?
Bem, o 1º lugar a observar são
as punições externas
e gratificações externas.
Uma coisa que podemos fazer
é simplesmente incentivar o
comportamento cooperativo.
Nós podemos fazer isso com
incentivos materiais,
como o aumento de dinheiro ou bens,
coisas que são valiosas.
Nós podemos fazer isso com
incentivos sociais.
Podemos ter marcadores de status
associados à cooperação.
Podemos trazer os custos da
reputação ao jogo.
E quando jogarmos os jogos do
dilema do prisioneiro
nas seções da semana que vem,
vocês terão a oportunidade de
experimentar todas essas coisas.
Ou podemos induzir certos tipos
de incentivos pessoais.
Podemos aumentar
liberdades e privilégios,
como resultado da cooperação.
E no que diz respeito a cada um
desses tipos de incentivos,
há contrapartidas punitivas.
Podem haver punições materiais
associadas à não-cooperação.
Podemos diminuir a quantia do dinheiro.
Podemos retirar alguns dos seus bens.
Podem haver punições sociais
associadas à não-cooperação.
Você pode enfrentar uma
redução do status
ou uma diminuição na reputação.
Ou podem haver custos pessoais
associados à não-cooperação.
Diminuição da liberdade ou
diminuição dos privilégios.
Então, esses são os tipos de
punições e gratificações
que podem ser impostos de modo
a alterar a estrutura de incentivos
do dilema do prisioneiro.
Mas, além de haver diferentes tipos
de incentivos e punições,
uma das coisas que é importante
reconhecer no pensamento
sobre esta questão é que também
pode haver diferentes tipos
de mecanismos de aplicação
colocados em jogo.
E isso acabará por nos trazer à
razão pela qual Hobbes pensa
que é necessária que tenhamos o
tipo de força externa
oferecido pelo governo.
Assim, por um lado,
poderíamos ter mecanismos de
aplicação que são intrapessoais.
Poderíamos criar dentro de nós
mesmos certos tipos de atitudes
que nos levam a cultivar o
comportamento cooperativo.
A consciência é uma instância de
uma solução intrapessoal
para os problemas de coordenação.
Você internaliza as normas sociais,
elas se tornam parte da sua
concepção própria e, como
resultado,
você se comporta de
maneira pró-social.
Poderia ser no contexto da
tragédia dos comuns.
Poderia ser no contexto do
dilema do prisioneiro.
Poderia ser no contexto do seu
próprio cultivo de hábitos
para superar o dilema do
prisioneiro temporal e intrapessoal
que todos nós enfrentamos em relação
às tentações do Angry Birds.
Poderia ser algum tipo de esquema
implícito ou explícito,
informal e interpessoal.
Assim, por exemplo, você pode adotar
uma estratégia de cooperar
na 1ª rodada do jogo do
dilema do prisioneiro e,
em seguida, seguir o exemplo de tudo
o que o seu co-jogador faz,
nas rodadas subsequentes.
Isso, como vocês sabem, a
partir da leitura feita,
é chamada de estratégia olho por olho.
E uma leitura suplementar, que eu
vou publicar para vocês,
seguindo o tópico de guerra
aplicado ao longo do curso,
é um maravilhoso artigo
de Robert Axelrod
sobre a evolução da estratégia olho
por olho na guerra de trincheiras
durante a Primeira Guerra Mundial.
Então, às vezes,
as estratégias
cooperativas informais
surgem
e de forma implícita ou
explícita as pessoas se envolvem
em círculos relativamente
estáveis ??de cooperação.
Podemos por em prática as
estruturas institucionais,
formais, interpessoais,
formais impessoais...
Coisas como as leis e o Estado,
onde existe uma regulação de
uma força externa.
E podemos, por último,
por em prática vários tipos de
controles tecnológicos.
Desligar a internet do seu computador.
Configurar os mísseis
durante a Guerra Fria
para que eles sejam lançados sem
a intervenção humana,
em certas situações.
E esses 2 podem servir a
função de aplicação.
Portanto, são inúmeras as formas de
escapar do Dilema do Prisioneiro,
do Problema dos Comuns.
E elas fazem uso de praticamente todos
os tipos de considerações
que nós analisamos este semestre.
Eu quero concluir fazendo
com que vocês vejam
que quanto mais claro pensamos
nas coisas desta maneira,
espero, melhor compreendemos a
parte final de Hobbes
que lemos para a aula de terça.
Você se lembram que eu apresentei a
1ª e 2ª leis de natureza.
A 1ª lei de natureza diz:
fazer a paz, sempre que possível;
reservar a guerra para
quando for necessário.
E a 2ª diz: abdicar dos seus
direitos exatamente
na medida em que os outros estão
dispostos a fazer o mesmo.
A 3ª lei de natureza, aponta Hobbes,
é a realização dos pactos;
mas ele lembra que você não será
capaz de seguir esta lei
exigida pelo interesse próprio
se você lidar com a possibilidade
da outra parte renegá-la.
Porque, se isso acontecer,
você vai se deslocar da 2ª
para a 4ª escolha.
E ninguém quer acabar lá.
Então, Hobbes diz que para ter pactos
que permitam crescer, prosperar
e adquirir os benefícios
da cooperação
deve ocorrer algum tipo de aplicação.
E o que Hobbes sugere é um
poder coercitivo
que obrigue igualmente os homens no
desempenho dos seus pactos
por meio do temor de alguma
punição maior que o benefício
que se espera obter pela
violação dos pactos.
Ou seja, Hobbes articula nas
passagens que lemos,
a partir do Capítulo 15 de O Leviatã,
uma das estratégias que, por
análise matemática do caso,
percebemos que seria suficiente
para mover as pessoas da
célula 3-3 para a 2-2.
Então, o que veremos na próxima
semana são 2 tipos diferentes
de justificações para os vários
tipos de estruturas sociais.
Veremos o apelo de John Rawls para as
nossas noções de justiça
e a discussão de Robert Nozick
sobre a noção de liberdade.
E as 4 pessoas a quem eu devo dinheiro
estão convidadas a vir recebê-lo.